Parliament committees have heard in
question Valdez Dombrowski's margarita
vista air and franz timmermans
executive vice president's designate for
the economy digital age and the European
Green Deal they've also put additional
questions to Yanis for tchaikovsky
commissioner designates for agriculture
val dastan brav schist has been
nominated for the economy that works for
people portfolio the former latvian
prime minister is the outgoing EU
vice-president for the euro and social
dialogue climates digital and democratic
changes are at the center of his program
europe's prosperity and our social
market economy a model are at stake we
need to manage this transition sources a
european economy works for all people
the executive vice-president designates
was hurt by the economic affairs in
employment committees they asked him how
he tackled the digital divide how it
promotes equal opportunities in work and
how he'd deal with the variety of labour
markets throughout the EU margaret
Avesta the outgoing Competition
Commissioner has been nominated as
executive vice-president for the digital
single market and competition she bound
to keep on working to create a level
playing field for European businesses
I've seen how enforcing competition
rules can make markets work for people
and not the other way around
I'm proud of the work that we have done
but there's still a lot to do MEP s from
the industry internal markets and
Economic Affairs committees questioned
her on various topics including
corporate taxation antitrust rules
support for small businesses and how to
ensure companies don't become too
powerful this is about rebooting our
society so that what we hold dearest is
preserved and improved for our children
grandchildren and future generations
we cannot afford the
screwing this up executive vice
president designate Fran's Timmerman's
defended the Green Deal portfolio in
front of the Committee on Environment
public health and food safety the
current first vice presidents of the
Commission vowed to enshrine in
legislation the --use 2050 climate
neutrality objective MEP squiz the
Dutchmen on the just transition fund for
climate change fossil fuels and the
engagement of young people across the
Union members of the Agriculture
Committee decided to put further
questions to Yanis fortunoff's key for
the agriculture portfolio after
assessing his initial performance MEP
said they needed a second opportunity to
decide whether the pole is qualified to
join the College of Commissioners I wish
to explain in more detail my vision
how to make European agriculture more
competitive innovative green and how to
make common agriculture policy more
efficient and fair 13 additional
questions were asked by M ETS including
further clarification on Common
Agricultural Policy reforms on u.s.
punitive tariffs on European products
and how to make farming greener the
votes in Parliament to decide if the
Commission as a whole is accepted or
rejected is scheduled for the 23rd of
October
[Music]